what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sockin pumped to be
talking about probing the cosmos we have
Luke Hawkins joining us on the show hi
Luke hello thanks for coming on the
program I'm glad to be here I'm so
pumped for this and it's so cool that
this is ten years later after us going
to high school together which is so
interesting to who we were ten years ago
who we are now a long time ago a long
ways away yeah yeah and now doing
cutting-edge radio astronomy which is
super interesting we love hosting shows
on space I'm very pumped on pack this
with you those who don't know Luke's
background he is a digital engineer at
the Green Bank observatory where he
designs a radio astronomy
instrumentation probing into our cosmos
on a myriad of global projects and you
can find the main link in the bio below
Green Bank Observatory org also the
Facebook Twitter and LinkedIn profiles
for Green Bank Observatory and Luke's
email all right Luke obviously you know
we've been hanging out today catching up
talking about big questions you know how
obsessed we are with this question what
is the point of reality why are we even
here I like to think that it's so that
humans can someday have an empire over
matter so that we can control everything
leave nothing to chance that I think
that is the eventual end goal and will
there be room for harmony with nature
and love as we do this empire over
matter
that's impossible to know until we have
the Empire but I don't see why they
would necessarily be mutually exclusive
okay okay we can lovingly have an empire
over matter right just having the
ability to control things doesn't
necessarily mean that you step in and
control everything you can have the
ability to cut down a tree and yet not
cut down the tree so to co-exist I think
it's definitely possible even if we do
have total control so in a sense it
would be to understand the reality that
we are in at the most source-code esque
levels and then reach some sort of a
highest possible state yep complete
understanding of everything and then
eventually the ability to manipulate
anything have no physical limitations
yes yes nothing being impossible yes is
the eventual end goal of reality I hope
will we be able to poke at the initial
reason why it was made in the first
place and then have a meta perspective
of why this was even made in the first
place maybe that's a that would be
really difficult to know so maybe does
it feel like we ourselves are going to
make quadrillions of simulations
ourselves of inevitably yeah and that
the little creations happening and yes I
believe humans will make many
simulations and we do simulations
currently yes yeah and as we go forward
our simulations will become more and
more from
advanced yeah and indistinguishable from
reality maybe there would be
consciousness in those maybe simulations
and maybe this is all cyclical and not
linear maybe we're a simulation now hey
we'll get to that later in this then
does that sick lissa t resonate that
rather than thinking linearly that
cyclically speaking that there has been
some sort of an evolution from
simplicity to complexity and then
complexity just makes more simplicity
and the cycle continues it really kind
of depends on the time scales that
you're talking about and kind of the
scale that you're talking about the when
you're talking about a cycle that has
maybe the age of the universe I don't
know if we get necessarily point and say
it will go throughout the arc of the
history of the universe that we will
have many cycles of complexity and
simplicity but I think on smaller scales
you can see these cycles possibly okay
as we're in this subject of the
grandness of this time scales of the
universe and the size of the universe
and the cosmos and probing into them we
have evolved quite a bit from our
initial days of just foraging for food
and observing just observing without
tools that were so scientifically
advanced that they could actually see
stars and planets quite well not only
our own in our solar system but beyond
that and also see other aspects to the
cosmos that even our own
eyes cannot detect so now we have built
those tools and now we are probing into
the cosmos at unprecedented rates and
given computation has also made this so
much better as well this has been a
trend that you are now immersed in and
you get to see firsthand and you got to
see three and a half years now yes yet
the Green Bank observatory in Green Bank
West Virginia using the Green Bank
telescope yes the Green Bank telescope
is a very big instrument it has a
collecting dish that is 100 by a hundred
and twenty meters parabolically shaped
it can receive radio signals from 100
megahertz to a hundred and sixteen
gigahertz it is fully steerable fully
moveable it is quite an engineering
marvel and we use it to probe some of
the universe's most difficult secrets so
this is this was built in 2000 yes and
prior to that we were also doing radio
astronomy let's do a breakdown okay
we're gonna get into all the nuance that
you just described about the the Green
Bank telescope and this is specifically
Radio Astronomy yes okay let's also
break down other types of probing into
the cosmos as well so probably the most
familiar one is like the Hubble
telescope yes that's a very popular so
let's explain that and explain like how
that and how like other like transit
photometry methods work like what a
Kepler and tests and what they're doing
and then how this is different and what
other methods there are because there's
there was like ultraviolet and there's
all these other crazy aspects to the
vegetarian spectrum so astronomy is
primarily an observational science so
that means that we we look we cannot set
up as many experiments as other fields
of science but we can look and so there
are optical of astronomy platforms that
people know you know fairly well like
the Hubble telescope and any other
telescopes that you would think of
Galileo's telescope and how Radio
Astronomy differs from optical Astronomy
and how all those other astronomical
instruments that you mentioned differ is
that you can look at the universe
through these different wave through
these through different wavelengths so
optical Astronomy is done at much higher
wavelengths at well optical visible
wavelengths so when the terahertz and so
as you move your opposite observational
frequency down into the RF or the
microwave or the IR ranges you can see
different things and also we find or we
know that the signals at some of these
frequencies are not as affected by say
clouds or other perturbations than
optical frequencies are so we can look
at the sky even when it's cloudy with
radio astronomy that's a synthetic
aperture radar right sar so there are a
few different ways you can do that I
can't comment too much on sorry okay
okay
which is so interesting yet being able
to do things like look through clouds
when you're using ground-based
telescopes this stuff is yeah super
important let's let's pass some time on
this as well like optical Astronomy
mostly being used to view stars mostly
being used to view planets light
reflecting off of their host stars onto
that planet and then into our
photometers that we're using to measure
that light that's what mostly stars and
planets for optical uh really anything
that's visible you could see I can't
comment too much on the percentage of
time that optical telescopes been
staring at stars versus planets versus
gaseous clouds massed rhoids yeah
so I different stuff okay we can look at
hey whatever you can see we can look at
okay and as far as how the percentage of
time breaks down I don't know okay and
then now look you know this is a very
classical question but like why radio
astronomy like you had you know optical
Astronomy radio astronomy you know why
even in the first place
astronomy and then why radio astronomy
for you and then we'll get into more
than you also the advent of radio
astronomy actually came on accident it
was I believe an engineer at AT&T Bell
Labs who's discovered that he started
getting static when the Sun came up on
it or I believe it was when the Sun came
up he started getting static on his on
his antenna at his house and he noticed
that the static started coming like six
minutes earlier every day and so he was
able to deduce that there was something
else or that there that the Sun was
giving off radio energy or that the
galaxy was giving off radio energy
and so it allows us to see things that
we could not see optically it allows us
to probe questions that we could not pro
optically and yes so then you wanted to
probe what we cannot see optically and
that was what kind of got you excited
yeah okay and also the book contact by
Carlos yeah yeah
yes so what do what do we like what what
then what then are we okay what are we
looking for with Radio Astronomy then
anything that isn't in like let's let's
build let's you know break this down
there's a visible light spectrum to us
in the electromagnetic spectrum and
that's 400 nanometers the wavelength the
wavelength to six 700 nanometer
wavelength 400 being closer to red and
and then even beyond that being closer
to radio so no it would be the 700 that
would be closer to radio and four sorry
400 being closer to ultraviolet yes
fast fast closer to ultraviolet 400-700
being longer yes longer wavelengths okay
at those longer wavelengths once we get
beyond 700 then I can't see it correct
and that's what the little like remote
controllers for your like TV and yep
Loretta yes okay they work at an
infrared frequencies so you can't see it
with your eyes but it is light it's it's
light it is like so those are that's a
stream of photons that are being emitted
from the remote controller to the TV yes
that I can't see yep and that's using
infrared yeah okay beyond a 700
nanometer wavelength okay so
now where is radio past that and then
what is the process of building a
telescope to try and look in the cosmos
for radio waves and why are we even do
like what are we looking for so uh what
are we looking for well there's a lot of
different a lot of different science
cases a lot of different science
questions that we're trying to answer at
the Green Bank Observatory we're trying
to answer how stars are formed what kind
of environment sets the table for star
formation we're trying to discover some
ore we're trying to discover new pulsars
characterize and study various galaxies
and all sorts of astronomical events
within our solar system and outside of
our solar system so there's a lot of
questions that the scientific community
doesn't have answers to and we're trying
to find answers to as many of those as
possible so then technically we should
have a telescope for every single
possible slot in the electromagnetic
spectrum pointed up into the cosmos yeah
ideally if you want it ideally you
wouldn't have full sky coverage across
the full bandwidth full sky coverage
full bandwidth yes so the bandwidth is
what we call the hundred megahertz to
the or yeah the hundred megahertz up to
the optical frequency okay with an
hundred megahertz being being the lower
limit of what is observable with the gbt
interesting okay and you listed star
formations observing galaxies pulsars
why are these things like what do
galaxies and pulsars star formations
what do they like emit during like how
like what kind of like what are they
doing how are they emitting radio
frequencies that
how are they doing that process and then
what are we seeing when we capture those
and try and analyze them so the emission
mechanism is different for each of these
events as far are for each of these
events as far as they how they actually
Ament emit the radio signals so I can't
comment too much on on the specific
mechanisms mechanisms but I can say that
it is different for each of these you
for these different types of
astronomical sources and as far as what
we actually see when we look at them say
you would see say 'ok there are
different molecules in that galaxies are
made of molecules and these different
molecules emit different frequency tone
or different yeah frequency tones of
signal and so say if you were looking at
a galaxy you could see that the tones
that represent the compounds that the
galaxy is made out of mm and so those
would show up essentially as like a line
of a solid or yeah like a line on a
waterfall plot whereas most ours or some
of these transients like pulsars or FRBS
the their signature is more of a pulse
or a beep so rather than a solid line
you would see a beep that covers more
bandwidth so we can view at a molecular
level frequency tones of a galaxy
distant from us and say what molecules
exist in that galaxy
yes and we're getting more and more
precise measurements every day okay and
then that type of a signal processing at
gbto Green Bank telescope looks
different than a pulsar signal
processing yes you're okay so different
algorithms are being used to process the
radio frequencies for the specific use
cases for star formations our Milky Way
molecules or pulsars correct so so for
some of these sources that aren't
changing in time like the galaxies or
stars like these are things that do not
they do not change the galaxy is still
going to be the galaxy it's compound is
not going to be or it's compound makeup
is not going to change over you know a
timespan of hours so what we can do is
you can average all the data for many
hours of certain observations and
compress that into a more dense data
package whereas for some of the more
transient sources you need the higher
time resolution to be maintained
throughout the signal processing chain
yeah Wow
so so so basically you're in a sense is
this big radio frequency bucket that
you're holding and pointing to the sky
and then you are holding it there for
long periods of times in many cases to
try and watch something for a long
period of time and other times you're
just looking for a short bit of time to
identify the one thing that you need and
move on and these are the different
experiments that you do there but I
before maybe we get into more on the
experiments I just I also want to review
these these numbers that you were
mentioning to us a little bit earlier
okay so this this is
this is a hundred meters in diameter of
collecting area yes it's very large so I
think you called I think you told me
that this is is this a football field
yes about the size of a football field
okay so this is the size of a football
field now let's um now okay obviously
the dish is the 100 meter collecting
that's how you're collecting the radio
frequencies right in the dish formation
and then there's there's a there's an
angle there's like a like a literally
like a like you could use like you can
use a joystick or something - literally
angle this puppy wherever you want in
the in the sky it's like that mobile yes
not a joystick but yes yeah if it's not
okay
yeah a more complicated joystick okay
and then and then that's nuts
so then you're moving this do you know
the weight I believe it's like 17
million pounds you're moving like yeah
like a 70 million pound object and you
have to like you know make sure that it
you know it stays in good healthy fluid
mechanical ability over time which is
what you need probably lots of repairs
and technicians and engineers to just be
doing that lots of maintenance lots of
maintenance and but it's cool because
you can upgrade the hardware over time
right yes this is very interesting
because when you cinch it up to space
you can't upgrade the hardware
bow-bow any hits on land you can at
least upgrade the hardware which is nice
over time as things get ya better so
then um what is the big what's what's it
called it's the this is the
it's an unblocked aperture so that's
what that's what the at the so unblocked
aperture meaning the actual the the
radiofrequency collection is unblocked
yes okay but then what is that big giant
thing that is jutting out from the side
of the dip from the edge of the dish up
from the up top yeah in this image it
would be from that yep from that's the
highest in this image yeah
okay what is that the jutting up so that
is the feed arm so the way the telescope
works is the large dish is the main
collecting area and then at that point
the main dish focuses all the energy
upwards in this image to either one of
the receivers or to the prime focus
collecting dish which then focuses it
again yeah into one of the receivers so
let's um let's let's look at this so you
your so then the the main collecting
dish is then focusing the radio signals
onto a processing unit its focusing the
signals onto say a dipole or horn
antenna and then at that point it goes
through the analog signal processing
chain after the analog signal processing
chain it is then digitized and then it
goes into the more full comprehensive so
first analog signal processing then
digital signal processing and the Cola
so the collection the collection is in a
sense it you said it's focusing it on to
that analog signal processing yes
interesting and so then in a sense this
is like the on on when you do optical
Astronomy this is when the light comes
and reflects off of the the mirrors
which then a way to focus it and then it
focuses it on that little tiny like
silicon yes reading the instrument now
SEC the CCD standing what it forgot on a
CCD okay and so then that unit then
processes the the photons that it
received it begins the digitize
digitizes it gosh okay okay okay okay so
that's so that is that what do you guys
call that part of the telescope so arm
the dish and then the yeah the arm the
arm and then it so then this so then
this part where all the signals are
being processed then that sends after
analog to digital signal processing then
that is what you guys get as a readout
on your computer yes so it is then the
the digital signals that are stored and
analyzed I'm I'm so I'm so curious as to
that algorithms and also the like of
course the complexity of actually taking
you know data of radio frequency data
from galaxies and from star formations
and pulsars and like and being able to
try and make sense of that and how you
guys actually like really just how do
you freaking know that it's actually
that like holy crap like how do you know
well so the the data is coming very fast
we deal with very high data rates so
that is part of the challenge and then
once we can process the data I mean you
can say look at a source and if you look
at a source take some data on a source
and then look at the data and if it if
the data says there's a source there
that we were looking at then you kind of
know that you did something right and if
the data says no source
you weren't looking at anything then you
know you got something kind of wrong so
you're already pointing at specific
areas where you're expecting you're kind
of doing trial two or trial three or
four you're testing it over you're doing
the scientific method sure you're in
yeah you want to make sure that the
evidence is coming in what's hard if
you're like a pulsar may only happen or
a star formation may only happen once in
that given area where it's happening but
then the Milky Way itself will continue
you could continue analyzing that over
time stuff like that okay what is up
with the whole this free this frequency
range point one to 116 gigahertz so
that's the length the wavelength yeah so
that that is the range of frequencies
that we are able to observe so you can
convert the frequencies to wavelengths
using the speed of light and an equation
so I don't know those up off the top of
my head but yes those are the that is
the range of frequencies that we are
able to observe with the gbt what do you
see at point 1 gigahertz and what do you
see at 116 gigahertz there you see a lot
of things I couldn't comment too much on
specifically what we are able to see it
the different across I couldn't break it
down for you into the different tranches
of frequencies okay because it seems
like that's that's huge
but there but in order for you to be
able to do that you have to be in a
radio silence zone Green Green Bank in
West Virginia is a radio silent zone yes
we are in the National Radio quiet zone
and the West Virginia radio quiet zone
no cellphones no no cellphones and
actually these zones these radio quiet
zones
are made of kind of conical sections so
that have stricter rules for the
sections near the center and lacks our
and lacks or rules as you get further
and further away so for example within a
mile of the gbt you're not even allowed
to have spark plugs ever vehicle that
goes close to the telescope needs to be
a diesel Wow yes so once you go a mile
away then you're allowed to have a spark
plug Kars ensure soon at my house I'm
not allowed to have microwaves I'm not
allowed to have Wi-Fi I'm not allowed to
have a Roomba or cellphones of course
yeah Wow and then once you get even
further away some cell towers are
allowed but they need to be coordinated
with the observatory Wow yeah so it's a
in in a sense you're doing your best to
make the as much signal as possible and
decrease as much noise which is why you
have these quiet zones radio quiet zones
interesting and that's why we put
telescopes telescopes up in very remote
locations that are very high elevation
as well decrease the amount of light
pollution decrease the amount of noise
that could potentially happen I'm
atmospheric perturbations yeah yeah yeah
yeah
are there radio telescopes in space yes
there was a Russian satellite that I
believe just went offline earlier this
year and I think Germany is launching
another one yeah okay um yeah okay this
is obviously an extremely difficult
engineering feat to shoot up a telescope
into orbit
we're until one of these Lagrange points
etc and like to be able to actually keep
it there this is a very expensive things
and but but it's but it's crazier
because you get better signal there's
less noise when you're in space yeah
exactly less microwaves less spark plugs
in space yeah yeah until the one
microwave it just comes flying through
the space is um I'm very curious this is
probably one of my one of my one of my
favorite parts to it which I'll actually
I think we should get to the
crowdsourcing stuff right after this I
want to hit this one first because since
we're actually talking about radio
frequency interference I want you to
teach us about this there's all these
different measures to decrease RFI radio
frequency interference all these
different measures but most recently
this machine learning this ability to
have identify patterns and then and then
take those patterns as a noise and
eliminate them so that you can keep as
much of the signal as possible and you
yourself have been going deep into the
machine learning to be able to do this
you published you were one of the
co-authors on a paper on it yeah so one
of the things that we're doing at the
Green Bank Observatory to reduce RFI in
addition to banning spark plugs and
microwaves and special kinds of certain
kinds of lights and all of those fun
things is we're also developing digital
or like digital signal processing
algorithms that will help us identify
and remove our of RFI at these extremely
high time resolutions so currently RFI
despite our best efforts does
contaminate the data we do see RFI in
in our observations and we expect to see
more and more as time goes on with
SpaceX's startling satellite project and
amazon's project Kuiper satellite
project self-driving cars with radar the
internet-of-things Bluetooth
connectivity everywhere RFI is is coming
for us and I am trying to build some
gates with machine learning so it's
we've had really promising results so
far
it's a tremendous amount of data to go
through to even just validate these
algorithms on you have to it is a
tremendous amount of testing that needs
to be done and a tremendous amount of
computing resources that is necessary
you're when you're when you're talking
about this explosion of of radio
frequency interference to me I'm always
wondering like how are we going to be
able to like what what are we foreseeing
has long-term implications of some of
these things that we're doing like when
you when you when you throw up this
fleet of tens of thousands of of
satellites into into orbit when you have
all of the autonomous vehicles or the 5g
technology or the Internet of Things
everywhere like can we just like test
some of these things in like a small
zone first to like you know this is what
the whole digital twin and simulations
come in handy where you can like you
know simulate out what actually happens
first before you implement it here in
this physical world because because
otherwise you have this like how are you
gonna be able to conduct your science
and who else around the world is
impacted who like can't conduct their
science anymore due to other people
trying to advance their science this is
a weird so in an ideal world yes any any
object that
generated RFI it would go through
extensive compliance agreements with
various observatories but these are
serious but these these projects that
generate the RFI like StarLink and hyper
these are serious business ventures with
serious money on the line and take it
they get approval yeah and will they be
promises for delivering great things to
civilization yes that's why so it's a
it's a balance between the two and at
the moment we're just trying to develop
new algorithms to help us coexist yeah
yeah interesting like as though this one
scientific party that's being more
seriously influenced by it has to like
you said develop algorithms to offset
the RFI of this scientific advancement
so that you can continue doing yours
it's very interesting how these things
play out like that Wow
and it's also just the big question
about like where we're going in our
future in general but that's some stuff
that we may talk about in a little bit
something that that is probably one of
my favorite parts about all of this
obvious is much more difficult for me to
understand the complex algorithmic
computer science of doing taking-off RFI
that's like that's much harder but this
is much easier for me and hopefully for
other people is crowdsourcing of ideas
for the Green Bank telescope and for all
of these incredible telescopes that we
have like literally is it really like
anyone in the world can submit an idea
for like a couple hours on the Green
Bank telescope and then you you have a
committee that'll be like this one gets
an 85 percent and this one that's
exactly the way it works is anybody can
submit a proposal for view
and then we have a committee that goes
through and essentially evaluates and
grades and ranks all of the proposals so
yes anybody you don't even need an
astronomy background I can submit a
proposal and if it's deemed to have
merit it will get the time interesting
and then what have you seen coming
through like has there been like
universities or other governments from
around the world or some some complete
like independent people that are just
wanting to conduct interesting science
like what's been like I guess the
percentages so I can't comment too much
on the percentages but what I can say is
that it does seem to be mostly
universities or people affiliated with
universities that end up submitting and
getting approved for these and then what
are they like asking to do like what
kind of studies do they are they like
star formations or what do they want to
do a wide variety of science at the gbt
so like you said we study star formation
we study pulsars we study gravitational
waves we even do some observations for
SETI so you can we provide of
observations for a wide variety of
science use cases okay and then you give
them the data yes okay you just pass
along the data so what you're doing yes
yeah interesting okay this seems like a
really good way to potentially like I
love crowdsourcing of ideas so so then
what does this look like if you know if
like if you have something so powerful
that can potentially probe into the
cosmos at one of the highest levels on
the entire planet are you guys
oversaturated with proposals do you guys
get too many proposals way more than
your 6500 hours that you're doing per
year yeah so I do
I believe that we do get more
applications than we have time to
satisfy so we are oversubscribed
interesting what would make a a radio
telescope even more badass flame
stickers
well I mean the easy answer is you could
always make it bigger you could always
put it in space you could always
increase the possible bandwidth that it
could receive there's all sorts of all
sorts of variables that you could tweak
to increase its badasses yeah
interesting how about uh okay on a on a
on a funding level this is also
something that I think is extremely
important talking about so this is
funded this is the fund the funding for
this is only ten million dollars a year
annually is the funding that's all you
need to run the Green Bank telescope and
you guys have like a hundred fifty ish
people there yeah that all sounds right
fifty and turns ish or fish summer
people come over so it increases by that
and is it all funded what is that what
is that organization called the American
you associated universities associated
universities Inc a you I associate
University sync and then the the
National Radio Astronomy Observatory
NRAO and Green Bank telescope are both
under that parent yes organization okay
and then the funding is federally
through the National Science Foundation
yes
the vast majority is okay and then so
that's taxpayer dollars that fund the
National Science Foundation which then
distribute we were looking it up
somewhere on like I think eight billion
or so dollars to a myriad of scientific
projects including green big telescope
is one of them so it costs like pennies
from each of us to do things like fund
this which is like a sip from a glass of
beer or whatever a bite of your sandwich
yes like come on like one bite of your
sandwich is like adding significant
scientific advancement into our world so
yeah yeah and I believe that the gbt
detected a planet made of diamond so I
think it'll pay for itself if we ever
get a space tugboat who can bring us
back this diamond planet pay for itself
of finding a diamond planet oh my
goodness okay so this is obviously
crucial just funding scientific
advancement and scientific projects like
this is such a such a such a cheap thing
from each of us to contribute several
pennies this is actually also something
that we're trying to figure out with
media as well because this is something
that is like you know we care so much
about content being completely not pay
walled period no pay wall ever yet at
the same time it's like it's like yo you
you as a dollar like if you love
watching this like give us a dollar give
us ten bucks you know like the links are
in the bio you know these are the little
things that you can do to support like
independent media or independent science
etc or government-funded science even
just but just really rally for more
scientific funding we're in this case
funding the independent artists around
the world eight people believe in this
is a very important thing when you look
at like Lorenzo de Medici you look at
like Michelangelo getting funding you
look at these
patrons to world-leading artists and
what could be rather than this like
hoarding mentality and like buying a 50
odd and a v watch and like all this
other kind of stuff we're very
passionate about that Luke I would love
to have just two yachts I think that
would be enough for me you're ridiculous
I'm you're trying to like patron artists
around the world to become their full
selves you're like two guys oh my
goodness okay now you gave us a little
bit into this you were talking about the
study of pulsars you um we haven't
talked about this when you have fast
radio bursts fr bees like what are we
what are we trying to discover with
these things will kind of like what does
it tell us about the cosmos well so if
our bees are kind of a mystery right now
I don't think that anybody knows for
sure what it is that is what they are so
on the radio astronomy side we can see
pulses and we have seen so many of these
these pulses that we can't explain
necessarily where they came from and we
group them together and call them fr
bees and so we while we don't know
exactly the mechanism that that causes
these pulses they are kind of mysterious
so this also kind of sounds like it's a
like the cosmos is a big mystery to us
and then we like taking these little
tiny like bits of data these these fast
radio bursts and then we say okay let's
uh let's let's let's let's try and take
these little tiny bits of data and like
group them together to try and
understand them better
so it's like getting tiny little like
whispers from the cosmos in different
ways and you're like trying to look and
like be like what does this mean the
universe is a big problem you have to
break it into small pieces yeah yeah
okay okay other thoughts on what on all
of the different aspects to radio
astronomy that you know that we may have
missed before we get into these other
questions at the then did you feel like
we should hit another Oh radio astronomy
well I just thought I would say that
it's a very international aspect of
science there are Radio Astronomy
observatories all over the world Chile
South Africa Mexico China plenty others
that I am forgetting but there are it's
a very international science I'm really
happy that you brought that up if we
want more global cohesion and
collaboration what a great way to do it
by like open notebook science style
collaborations to build a more cohesive
collaborative social fabric around us
yeah it is a big global effort there's
so many different especially astronomy
astronomy itself is a very specifically
like a quite a a more like global
perspective in terms of trying to
advance a science whereas like if you're
in you're like maybe biology lab trying
to do genetic engineering or something
you're like how do I like we all share
the Stars
ya can't share lab equipment so easily
but we can share the stars yeah yeah
like I like that that's a great point
glad you brought that up and hopefully
it can do things like um catalyze that
overview effect where we all realize
like the pale blue dot of Carl Sagan
just that everyone and everything that's
ever lived that we know of has been here
so like please collaborate please work
together effectively yeah it's been it's
been a great journey and it will
continue being an incredibly interesting
story that unfolds yes
okay um other any other thoughts on
Radio Astronomy before we get to the
questions that's very interesting and uh
yeah I urge everyone to read more about
it yeah no kidding especially like like
Luke was telling me about like living
out there for three and a half years and
then you're just like I want to get an
apple we're like a mango or a pineapple
or whatever you want to get we're like
use a cell phone but like you have to
drive an hour to buy a pineapple
like I love pineapples I don't want to
drive an hour one direction to get a
pineapple but it's a sacrifice I make
yes yes this is also like boom like
those types of yeah sacrifices too yeah
yeah there's like all those nuances that
you talked about regarding like only
being able to drive the diesel cars
within a mile of it like there's no
spark plugs this is very interesting
stuff no microwave no cell phone like
there's other side there's sacrifices
like yes yeah and because of those
sacrifices the town around the
observatory is a very small town hence
the lack of apples and pineapples and
slack eventless but you got to know the
people and get to know the people yeah
you get to know the environment around
you
okay let's dive into questions that we
like asking at the end of the show um
the first one you know given the fact
that we're probing the cosmos we must
ask where is the space economy heading
does it we're gonna actually be sending
people to celestial bodies maybe towards
like the end of our lifetimes and these
like the kids of maybe maybe our kids
and the gen Z kids maybe they'll
actually get to go to the celestial
bodies this is gonna trigger the whole
space economy thing and well uh I don't
know but I would definitely like to see
a colony on Mars of the moon in my
lifetime yeah likewise yeah I would
definitely like to see yeah
colonies and other solar systems in my
lifetime that might be a stretch but
yeah
me too yeah those are pretty far away
yeah yeah but for sure how I'm very
optimistic about the future of space
yeah yeah and that's one you know one
component is doing this settling
settlement into the cosmos and another
one is just like space economics in
terms of like who's bringing these
payloads up into the actual space and
then into orbit and then what are those
satellites actually doing up there
you know what data are they collecting
and then who's gaining access to that
data how are they observing the planet
what when we collect that data is it
four there's some really interesting
like use cases with data that we collect
from satellites like observing
deforestation or observing ocean
acidification or there's all different
yeah exactly yes yeah ground earth
monitoring satellites for scientific
applications has so many uses weather
forecasting
climate modeling or climate studying yes
so many uses yeah
earth modeling Earth Observation for
climate studying yeah how many trees
there are yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah and hopefully also used for the
purposes of benevolence always always we
got it ethically and morally and
spiritually advanced fast enough as our
technologies become godlike in order for
us to make it through the little pinhole
that is approaching of the exponential
technology age do you feel similarly ah
I might say it's a little larger than a
pinhole but yeah yeah yeah I hope we're
responsible future with our technology
and what would you say is like a core
like principle that we can embody in
order to make sure that that we are
responsible with our technology Ori so
many giggles right now or he's on the
giggle bus right now but what's on well
it's what's funny are you enjoying over
there
he's so happy
or he has a recurring image in his head
of me in a funny position that is or
eise giggle bus right now
okay so as far as how to limit the bad
effects of Technology yes I would say
that some important things to do would
be to think about all the effects that
the technology would have before you
implement it and try and limit or
completely eliminate any of the negative
effects and secondly once a new
technology is implemented is - would be
to continually re-evaluate the effects
of the technology and have that be a
loop where you evaluate the effects you
adjust your operation of it and so on
and so forth yeah yeah I like that
that's that that's crucial and then I
think there's even something that's even
more first principle than that which is
there's this this evolution of our own
consciousness prior to making the
technology just how can you how can we
be traumatic all in than building
technology it's inevitable that when we
carry hatred rather than love that we're
gonna build something that then
catalyzes malevolence I mean it's just
like roots roots roots and roots are for
me know thyself work on yourself be
loved be kind and then work on building
all these technologies and doing this
feedback loop and like yeah deep
connection to each other and to nature
and to why we're here all the type of
stuff yeah sometimes I might do some
work before before the coffee fully
kicks in and so maybe I might do some
work when I'm not fully kind but once 10
a.m. kicks in and the coffee kicks in I
do all my work when I'm kind
that kind of also gets us into the
exponential technology age in general
what's something that like young kids
should embody as they go into this age I
had flexibility adaptability of
Technology is out like you said
accelerating exponentially you don't
know what you will need to know five
years from now so be ready to adjust
yeah
damn that retraining is nuts we're
talking like we've known long careers
for a while and I mean AI is eating our
world and in the ways that we ourselves
are going to be applicable creatively if
the windows are closing actually we
can't make as many permutations of
creative solutions to complex issues as
quantum computers can there's a lot of
stuff right there - what how do you feel
about it
well quantum computers are on their way
but they're not quite here yet
I would say so there's still plenty of
plenty of room and plenty of jobs for
creative talented humans and I don't
think that's gonna change in my lifetime
you'll definitely change a lot in your
lifetime in 50 years in 2070 there's
gonna be AI everywhere there's gonna be
AI a lot of places but 50 years is a
long ways out it's difficult to make
these predictions about what will and
will not be absolutely sure it just
really feels like it'll be hard to for
people to find meaningful creative
things to do every single day
but people have been saying that to
every time there's a kind of an
industrial revolution people say all not
a job they're going away fair but not at
this scale this is this is a yeah well
we'll we'll see we'll step again and uh
what 2609 369 empty years from now yeah
we'll see and then we'll replay this
episode jump right in
yeah yeah it's we're not even gonna need
to be doing the talking all these ideas
will have already worked themselves out
and maybe I'll have two yachts oh my
gosh and maybe we'll have patron
millions of artists around the world to
pursue their creative passions yes
before the two yachts maybe all of them
can come and hang out on the on the
yachts and do their art is humanity a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence maybe accidentally maybe
yeah maybe it will turn out that we were
accidentally that but we'll see not like
a determined just an accidental it may
be that we stumble into building digital
super intelligence but exactly not our
destiny as all we did for the last three
five minutes was talk about AI taking
over everything and now it's like oh
it's gonna be an accident like come on
like it's pretty much like we were just
talking about it so vehemently like with
such gnosis and now we're like oh it's
might be an accident
wait no well so I guess that depends on
how how I interpreted your your original
question is are we here to be
bootloaders like I took that as were we
placed here with the intention of just
being bootloaders for a digital super
intelligence
they know we were put here I don't know
I don't know but we're here and we might
end up just accidentally being
bootloaders for digital super
intelligence but what were we put here
by the Big Bang what made the Big Bang I
don't know if science gave a little bit
of room for mysticism magic spirituality
they could potentially harmonize better
on complex questions like that do you
feel that way maybe I don't necessarily
think that it's Sciences responsibility
to make room for that though I think
[Music]
science is what it is science is plenty
of room for intuition a lot of people
into it
what's beyond the edge of science and
they plant some sort of like a flag way
beyond the edge and then they do
rigorous science over decades to get
closer and closer to that and then they
go that intuition was right yeah so
that's where intuition or spirit or
feeling or emotion or all these other
sorts of ways of interpreting some sort
of a divine connection a to this feeling
that I'm having about something and then
being able to say now is it possible for
me to scientifically work my way to that
that I've hypothesized and that's I
think this room that I'm talking about
maybe if you want I would I would call
that a hunch I guess you could have a
hunch that something will turn out this
way and we call this mission this yeah a
spiritual whole it's a spirit sized hole
you know donut tough science it's almost
as though like this word like hunch is
like trying to in a sense just be like
how can I like avoid
spirituality or like you know intuition
or you know it's like just call it like
what it is like so many scientists
before us have been extremely spiritual
and they've made tremendous advances and
I think this is again I think these two
things marrying is a big part of our of
our ethos and it can potentially lead to
it's so funny because science in many
ways is just catching up to what people
over the last hundreds of thousands of
years have been aware of really like the
deep interconnectedness that people have
to the land that they're on to the
animals and plants and to each other
that they're in tribes with this is
something that's ancient AF like hella
far back and like only now are we are we
looking back and saying that oh now we
can scientifically prove that when you
go into a forest that your cortisol
levels decrease so you should spend less
time in little rat boxes and metropolis
is and you should spend more time in
forests because it's healthy for
decreasing your stress levels it's like
really well to be fair they had fewer
rat boxes and metropolis is thousands of
years ago so fair yes the cultural
analysis of that yet at the same time
it's like just even that in itself is
like really we need to have a rigorous
like you you like we'll have we really
become so disconnected and so separated
into our own egos that it doesn't
register that me feeling empathy or me
asking this first principled question of
why I'm even here and what is this
reality that I'm a part of or how do I
connect with the environment that I'm in
why does it feel like my stress levels
decrease when I'm immersed in nature all
these types of things really I mean like
if science and spirit could
kind of harmonized on that a little bit
more we could move the edge faster well
I'd be the first person to say that I
don't know everything so maybe that is
maybe there is more room for it than I'm
giving it credit for oh maybe not yeah
I will also agree that I am just know
very little and that I would also like
to just urge people to care more about
the marrying of science and spirit and
where that could potentially lead us do
we have free will I think so and what
gives you that thought
I feel pretty free in my life I guess I
do
sometimes I yeah I feel I feel free so
therefore I am free what is
consciousness the ability to doubt why'd
you pick that it was the first thing I
thought of and
it just strikes me as a very I don't
know kind of not necessarily human but a
very biological thing like I don't
computers don't doubt but humans do and
so maybe once a computer could doubt
then it could be said to be conscious
hmm but they have doubt in yourself or
doubt yeah maybe doubting yourself is
what consciousness is to me hmm what do
you think it is everything everything is
consciousness so do you think this is
conscious yes
yeah so there is nothing that is not
conscious yeah we are that we are all
fat are we really all one is that a
question how do you feel I feel good
are we all really one Luke we may be I
think each person is an individual I
think each plant is an individual plant
is there something deeper something
hidden tying all these individuals
together maybe maybe not
it's something that I don't know enough
to even guess do they all come from the
same source all the individuals yeah in
what sense do all of their lineages go
back to the same source did it all come
from one I honestly don't know from one
from one Big Bang is that a one is the
Big Bang of one I would say so I don't
care what people want to call it Big
Bang source God creation infinite
consciousness I don't give up what
people want to call it just commune with
exactly that and all of our problems
will be solved
that's how I feel I think that if
nothing else is a very good start I feel
really good feels like when we were
first talking earlier today about
interconnectedness and diving into that
that was very interesting and here we
are again talking with oh man are we
connected or just effective I know that
was your who knows your point is this a
simulation I don't know if it is it's a
pretty good simulation
I don't have a way to her to know so I'm
gonna say I don't know and it may be
that with our scientific tools we may be
able to probe at exactly that question
which I really look forward to yeah
that's a very interesting part of that
question and what do you think is the
most beautiful thing well for kind of a
hokey answer I'm gonna say my new kitten
titi is the most beautiful thing but to
give a better answer I don't know just
the complexity of the world just so many
things are happening and it all ends up
working like the Sun rises the Sun sets
it just keeps going on and on and I
think that's kind of beautiful but also
titi my kitten yeah yeah you are
interconnected with your cat you know
that when you walk home walk in walk
home you know there's a deep emotional
connection that happens with that cat
maybe so but to the the skunk's and the
deer I say on my drive home I am not
connected they affect me but I am not
connected to them and it may be
interesting to hear how your perspective
may change on thoughts like that in in
the future yes maybe so
people change thoughts change yeah yeah
it's interesting how you think that
you're interconnected with your cat but
not with the deer or the skunk that's
interesting that you like pick things to
be interconnected with but not others
like the trees that breathe out what you
breathe in you're not interconnected
with them
no they affect me but I'm not
interconnected with them
like that process isn't an
interconnected process when they breathe
out and you breathe in like and you
breathe out and they breathe in that's
not a interconnected process
it seems so like semantics yeah I think
this is mostly a semantic disagreement
probably in that I feel like connected
connectivity has a lot of weight behind
it so for something to me to rise to the
the level of saying connectivity to
something that's a pretty hefty hefty
goal and I just I can't say I'm not
connected to the skunk's I say on the
try fault and it may be that ever since
the first moment everything is and has
always been and will always be
interconnected it could be and it may be
that when the child is born into the
world that the child knowing that they
are interconnected and having parents
and community and lifestyles around
feelings of interconnectedness could
heal all of the problems that we have
all of the excessive self dealing all of
the treating nature like [ __ ] all of the
mental health problems all of the
economic machinery and people feeling
like they're like they're squares trying
to be pushed through circular holes in
the economic machinery yeah absolutely I
think just better understanding how you
fit how you fit into to everything else
and yeah I'm cognizant of how the
district decisions you make and the
choices you make how those affect other
things another yes people that's yes
important and a great way to make the
world a better place being aware of how
you connect to everything else being
aware of how you affect everything else
Luc Hawkins thank you so much for coming
on the show brother thank you thank you
very much thank you it's been such a
pleasure it really appreciates you so
much it's so cool ten years later the
bros are together doing a podcast after
working at the Green Bank Observatory
for three and a half years after doing
the show for two years we got together
to do this show after all of our fun
endeavoring in high school I'm really
happy we connected on debate that's
actually a big thing seriously
yes debate was one of the most
influential things that both Luke and I
ever did and highly recommend it yeah
highly recommend our world cares more
about debate and nuanced uh dialectic so
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
about probing the cosmos in general let
us know what you're thinking about
astronomy instrumentation in general
check out the links in the bio below to
Green Bank Observatory dot org also
their Facebook Twitter LinkedIn pages if
you want you can email Luke as well also
thank you Ori Shapiro for co-producing
great appreciate thank you and for all
the great giggles in the back and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders in your communities that you
believe in support them and help them
grow you can find all of our links in
the bio below on PayPal patreon
cryptocurrencies help support us even
those little donations help a lot please
InDesign cool merch and get paid all
those links are in the Bible oh and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world to build that
neck
the world tap into those feelings that
we talked about on the episode we love
you very much thanks for tuning in we
will see you soon everyone peace